Me siento muy frustrado por
la respuesta del gobierno a
este brote y siento que se
podría haber evitado mucho sufrimiento
al tener acceso más temprano a las vacunas y
cosas así.
En el transcurso de mi doctorado me di cuenta de
que quiero  estar más involucrado con
los pacientes, no sé, es difícil
seguro, creo que hay muchas
fuerzas opuestas, pero
al mismo tiempo,
así es como es todo y
sí, tenía una buena cantidad de ellos en
mis brazos,
así que
aquí hay un lugar  aquí pueden ver que
todavía está un poco rojo.
Tenía algunas lesiones que eran internas, um,
no solo en mi piel, sino también en las
membranas mucosas de todo el cuerpo,
básicamente, y esas eran las que
eran muy dolorosas, así que
antes de comenzar con la medicación y
antes.  Pude obtener medicamentos para el dolor
de mis médicos. El dolor era tan intenso
para mí que básicamente tomaba
baños tibios seis o siete veces al día solo
porque eso era lo único que
me haría sentir mejor.
Este es uno bastante típico, así que  este fue el
que les mostré en mi brazo,
esto es bastante típico de las lesiones de viruela del mono
después de un par de días, así que es un
bulto elevado con una pequeña hendidura en
el medio,
así que casi todo el mío se veía así
en algún momento,
pero era  como
levantado y parece un grano en la
reserva nacional, tenemos vacunas,
tenemos millones de dosis del tratamiento de la tetera
disponibles y,
meses después de este brote, todavía
no podemos movilizar esos
recursos y
como alguien que tenía  viruela del mono y me
recuperé de eso, es muy
frustrante verlo porque no quiero que
nadie tenga que pasar por lo que yo
pasé y parece que
podríamos estar haciendo más
contigo